I heard about how you can do machine
learning in looker now how does that
work do I have to be a data scientist to
use it because I'm not no definitely not
it's actually intended for the average
looker user let me show you
[Music]
hi Chris it's great to have you join us
today uh can you tell us a little bit
about yourself thanks Martin and thanks
for inviting me so I'm the machine
learning accelerator lead at Google
Cloud before joining Google about three
years ago I worked as an economist doing
public policy research mostly for state
and federal agencies
oh so you must know a lot about machine
learning and statistics now we're
talking about machine learning in looker
today first off can you tell us what
looker is absolutely so Lookers Google's
Enterprise business intelligence
platform for analyzing and acting on
governed data many large organizations
use it to build custom data workflows
that Empower business users to make
better decisions with data why would I
want to do machine learning in looker
that's a great question well because it
allows the business analysts to use
Predictive Analytics as part of their
business intelligence workflows it
brings the power of Google machine
learning to the business user I see can
you show us how to get started sure
first you'll want to find the machine
learning accelerator in looker
just ask your looker admin to install it
from the looker Marketplace if you don't
see it under the applications menu all
right opening it now it looks like you
don't have any models yet let's create
one go ahead and click the create new
model button
got it you're looking at a model
creation guide Now Let's Pretend We're a
bi analysts at a regional Airline and we
want to predict customer satisfaction
why do I have to predict customer
satisfaction don't customers fill out
surveys for that kind of thing well some
customers complete a satisfaction survey
but most don't and we care about all of
our customers experience for example the
airline might want to reach out to
frequent flyers who likely had a poor
experience recently even if they didn't
fill out a survey makes sense also I'm
really curious about what factors are
the most important for predicting
customer satisfaction
is it if the flight was on time uh or
could it be the amount of leg room or or
something else that's a great question
let's find out first we need to choose
an objective all right I see two
objectives uh which one do I choose so
our machine learning model will predict
whether or not a customer is satisfied
with their flight which means we're
trying to predict a category or class I
see so I'll click on predicted category
and now what do I do well right now we
see a list of looker explorers you'll
want to select the Airline customer
satisfaction Explorer to build your
input data set to train the model okay
now this looks familiar to me it's like
a normal looker Explorer What fields
should I select for my input data so
there are a few fields we know we want
to include for sure we definitely want
to include the overall satisfaction
field because it includes the outcome
we're trying to predict that makes sense
you'll also want to make sure you filter
in that field so that we don't have any
rows with null values why do I want to
do that well the algorithm needs to know
the answer to train the model so rose
with null values are not really helpful
got it okay I filter out rows with null
values now you should select the
passenger ID field because we want our
data to be at the passenger level that
makes sense what other fields should I
pick so now this is where your
experience flying comes in you should
select fields that you think contribute
to overall customer satisfaction What
fields do you think will help us predict
if a passenger enjoyed their flight oh
all right let's see here I'm going to
pick seat Comfort in-flight
entertainment
ease of online booking
legroom
under rival delay how do those sound to
you Chris those are all great
intuitively we would expect them to be
correlated with the outcome but you
should also consider some other fields
that describe the passenger for example
business Travelers might value different
factors than Leisure Travelers okay so
I'll add customer type and type of
travel so now just click the Run button
like you would do in any looker Explorer
done and should I click continue now yes
and this brings you to the next step
which asks you to name your model and
review the summary statistics for your
input data got it uh now what to use as
my target here so the target is the
field from your input data that contains
the values you're trying to predict in
this case it's overall satisfaction ah
that makes sense and now do I click
generate summary yeah so now we can
review our summary statistics to help us
decide if we want to keep all the fields
we selected in our models training data
you can also access advanced model
options from that gear wheel at the
bottom is there anything I should
uncheck or or change here no the
application automatically identified the
passenger ID column and deselected it we
wouldn't want to train a model using a
unique ID like that I like that the
application keeps me from doing anything
wrong should I click on create model now
yeah we're ready to create your first
machine learning model now this can take
several minutes for the model training
to learn all the patterns in the data ah
perfect I need a cup of tea anyway
and we're back uh did my model finish
training it looks like it when the model
finishes training we see its valuation
metrics you can use those metrics to
compare the performance of different
versions of your model oh uh like if I
decided to add or remove fields and run
it again exactly it's an iterative
process to continue improving the model
now I really want to see what's the most
important factor in determining customer
satisfaction can I actually you can just
click on the feature important screen
and you'll see
huh look at that it was seat comfort and
in-flight entertainment that's not what
I had expected so what can I do with a
machine learning model like this once
it's created
so now you can predict if a customer is
satisfied with their flight even if they
don't respond to a survey sounds good
let's create some predictions let's do
it just click the continue button uh oh
and now I see the looker Explorer UI
again do I pick the data that I want to
use to get predictions exactly and
you'll notice that looker already
selects the required Fields so you'll
just need to update your filters so what
should I filter on well we'll want to
get predictions for when overall
satisfaction is missing meaning the
customer did not respond to our survey
okay now I just click the Run button
that's correct looker is now running a
query against the data in bigquery now
that you have the data you want to score
just click the generate predictions
button
that's so cool so now I see the
predictions in Gray on the left now your
predictions are accessible in bigquery
in a local mail developer can add them
to a liquor Explorer for building
visualizations and dashboards
I've actually already created a
dashboard for you as an example go to
your main menu and open the shared
folder okay got it
and now open the Airline customer
satisfaction predictions dashboard
oh and and here I see that we have the
number satisfied and dissatisfied
customers uh so how would a business
take action with this new insights well
in looker you can drill into Data to get
more detail about high-level metrics so
you can click on the dissatisfied
customer account and see which customers
we think did not enjoy their flight even
if they didn't respond to our survey ah
I see so If This Were Real data I could
reach out to these customers and offer
them a free upgrade on their next flight
exactly there are likely many ways a
business might respond to knowing which
customers were likely least satisfied
with their service with looker you now
have the power to identify those
customers well Chris I'm not a machine
learning guy but I like how even I was
able to build a prediction model with
just a few clicks
now let's say people who watch this want
to get started with machine learning
accelerator uh what can they do well
first they should ask their looker admin
to install the application from Liquor
Marketplace then they can begin building
machine learning models and using their
predictions
and what are some common use cases that
would benefit from machine learning
models
possibilities are really endless but
we've seen customers use these models
for things like marketing and Supply
Chain management use cases thank you for
showing us this Chris and thank you
everyone for watching if you have any
questions for Chris or me add them in
the comments section below also let us
know if there are any serverless topics
you'd like to see in future episodes we
read every single comment
until next time
[Music]